Michael I'm so excited to talk with you
again I feel like it's the summer of
Michael between Transformers rise of the
Beast and Jack Ryan and no special ops
lioness on Paramount plus so that's
gonna be fun for you oh I feel so
grateful I'm I'm having a I'm having a
blast it's kind of all perfect timing
with us uh you know being on strike I'm
like all right cool get to go out and
promote the the wonderful projects that
I'm so fortunate enough to be a part of
yeah and one of the most wonderful
projects now is the new one you've got
coming out on Paramount Plus in July
let's talk about special ops lioness
which is inspired by an actual U.S
military program and after watching the
premiere and personally reading more
about it it's incredible how this was
constructed and just what the outcomes
were so how much did you know about the
real program before signing up for the
series I didn't I I uh well Taylor
pitched it to me he we had we had a call
um and and I was me being the guy that I
am was totally into CIA and the
government and politics and everything
that I'm into personally in my real life
I was just like oh my god dude this is
so up my alley you know sort of to show
the the theater of world politics and
world you know what what's what's really
going on
um it was just so at Miley I was like
I'm in I'm in I'm in a man and Taylor I
think he's just a genius like I was so
excited yeah it's so funny I was gonna
ask you about that because it's funny
that I see you in House of Cards and
then I see you in Jack Ryan and I see
like as always government operatives in
something or the other so you are a
political junkie you're somebody who
devours that news all the time oh 100
this is all just setting up my political
career that's all I'm doing of course
it's totally fine so um Taylor Sheridan
he is known to really create these
worlds that are so Dynamic and they're
really involved
um what was it about the script that
just really Drew you to the series
besides the politics and like there's
these real characters there's these real
like he really fleshed out these
characters in this um first episode I
got to watch and yeah what were you a
fan of his work also prior to yes I was
a fan of his work
100 a fan of his work we had met before
in a different project that
I but I think what really drew me to
this besides like we just talked about
the CIA and the government all that kind
of stuff but it was the fact that this
was
such a
large female driven power driven female
characters
running and there was something so
compelling to me about not just that but
that you got to see how that sort of
thing affects them
at home as well as at work and how the
two cross over uh and I think it's it's
written so brilliantly where
um the the two worlds are equally
fascinating you know uh and and and and
going back and forth you're just like oh
my God what's happening now like but
that these women are at the center of it
and that they got such incredible actors
from obviously Zoe and Nicole that
everyone's familiar with but Liza this
girl is a Powerhouse and she shines in
this show like I haven't seen someone
pop in a long time and it's I just feel
grateful to be a part of it in any way
shape or form and it's really rare I
feel like to see on TV you know
female-led shows where they're in these
roles that are traditionally male-led
roles like being in the Marines we're
always thinking about guys but then for
women who are actually Marines and we
get to see the lives they LED and like
the missions they were on and it
obviously all takes toll PTSD and the
trauma they've experienced yeah I you
know it's it's uh I I always say like
the world would be a better place if we
let women run a lot more
the show does it man and it's and it's
it's it's incredible uh that you have
what you would say is
typically your male World your male show
that is a bunch of women just kicking
ass and it's
so so much fun it's so good you know so
good yeah I'm excited what your
character Donald Westfield he oversees
the program with Nicole Kidman's Caitlyn
Mead and you made quite an impress the
first episode so while we see a glimpse
of you what more can we expect and like
what can you tell us about Donald and
how he operates you know he is
because I I don't say anything you can
expect because I don't want to ruin
anything but he is a man who obviously
uh cares so much about what he does and
gives so much to the cause so to speak
um
but he's really good at what he does as
well and so his relationship with
Nicole's character Caitlyn is
when you see for the first time I I hope
Elise that it's conveyed the history
that the two characters have that
there's a trust amongst the two of them
that they you know
they wholeheartedly trust one another
because unlike Caitlyn Westfield has to
answer or to a further extent Westfield
has to answer to the higher ups you know
the administration the the president and
his men
um their staffs it's that's that's the
difficult and tricky part and tricky
Waters that Westfield has to tread that
she doesn't have to as much
um so it's it's a it's a fine balance uh
that he's that he's having to to ride
but ultimately you know
he does what he believes is the right
thing no matter what the consequences
are and I like that about him yeah and I
I love seeing like they're all these
strong female characters on the show but
you know you being in the mix with that
you're sparring basically on screen with
Nicole Kidman's character and Zoe
Saldana is like what's it like working
with those two and having those
sometimes intense scenes it was
incredible you know my first day I'll
tell you this was this was really cool
um I go in and I I pride myself on being
someone who's always ready I don't want
to be the guy who ever holds up
production because I don't know
the scene as well as I should or my
lines as well as I should or I haven't
thought about everything so I I came I
went to work prepared especially the new
guy you know like this is you know those
girls are executive producing and
and I'm just showing up to do the work
that I'm doing and uh
I always bring my sides for rehearsal
and I walk in and the two women we kind
of all come in the same time and and I
noticed that neither of them are
carrying sides and I'd sort of take mine
and quietly slide them under one of the
CIA folders top secret I was like yep
I'm gonna put that right here
um because I was ready but I just always
have them you know and I was like wow
it's that kind of set you know where
rehearsal is not about getting to know
the scene rehearsals about like where
are you gonna be uh where are you going
to be sitting this is where I'm going to
be sitting you know
um just seeing the a game that these
women brought to work it was it was
beautiful man it was I was so thrilled
to to
to get in and and just play with those
girls they're they're amazing yeah well
you hold your own I feel like from what
I've seen so far and I know that you're
going to be able to like you know really
develop this character in the next
episodes but um yeah from the looks of
the premiere I don't think you'll be
engaging in any other stunts but like
was there challenging scene or maybe a
moment you shot that your co-stars that
ended up being kind of hard or just
taking a toll because I know you're very
used to doing stunts I am I am and I
love it and I and I miss it but it's it
I think what took a toll you know look I
had it easy compared to everybody else
like those guys out there sweating it
out in the sun in the desert wearing all
that gear I've done it I know what it's
like it is not easy it's fun but it is
not easy so for me the most challenging
part was just getting some of the scenes
that I had down to memory
um that's honestly always the hardest
part for me is just memorizing
um you would think I'd be better out of
doing what I do for a living but I'm not
so
um that that was probably the toughest
part was jumping in and
trying to let go of whatever nerves I
had you know being a part of something
that I thought was really special and
just trying to let it all go and just be
you know it was difficult
um but rewarding in the end if you could
describe uh this show with a word what
would you say just one word I would say
captivating or thrilling one of those
like it's just really
you know
I I think
one of the greatest thing about it was
was getting those scripts and everyone
that I got
ripping through them like it was I just
couldn't wait to see what happened next
and then having seen the first episode
now I'm like oh my God it translated to
the screen exactly that feeling that I
had reading it and that's all you can
ask for in a show as far as I'm
concerned is as you or C can't wait to
see what happens the next minute that's
a you know you're a part of something
special when that happens
and it's not always yeah and I'm really
excited for everyone to see it and
before I do let you go
um I'm having so much fun chatting with
you I want to keep it in the Paramount
family and I want to ask you about
Transformers rise of the Beast of yours
uh for years I'm just I was so excited
to see you in those final moments I was
like oh of course he would be in this
scene of course I'm wondering
um being like the VIP bridging
Transformers to GI Joe what was your
reaction when you got that especially
since it was so top secret leading up to
that day it was so cool because I met
I met him many years ago we had a coffee
in Los Angeles it was set up by our
agents or whatever you know let's have
coffee this guy he's a great up and
coming director he had just finished
doing Creed and I was like yeah I want
to meet him and we sat down and the two
of us hit it off and we talked for like
an hour or two
it was years ago pre-pandemic like and
nothing ever came of it never talk to
him again and then one day I get this
call to the blue saying hey Steven wants
to jump on the phone with you they're
finished with principal photography on
Transformers but he wants to talk to you
about an idea he has and he called me
and he pitched to me what
this was in this film which originally
was going to be an end credit or post
credit scene post credits post credits
and then they they ended up making it
the last scene of the film for whatever
reason but
um when he pushed it to me and then he
was like you know and then there's this
old GI Joe world and we're not sure that
we have the right suit yet but we really
want to tie in the Two Worlds and I just
think it would be this really cool idea
and when we shot it we shot it with a
couple different cards that I gave him
that I give him you know the not the one
that you see is not the only one we shot
and I was just so thrilled to be a part
of it like you know I have 11 year old
boy and I was like this is going to be
cool when he's either you know and uh
and I thought it would be fun to jump
into one of those franchise worlds
especially one that I grew up on
Transformers GI Joe like that's what I
you know I'm 54 I grew up with both of
those
um so so for me to be a part of that it
was just it was thrilling man it was
like really cool and if nothing else
comes of it nothing else comes of it but
it might sounds like they might do
something yeah I feel like agent Burke
is gonna be like the Nick Fury of the
Cinematic Universe you know we see a lot
more with him but um
for sure but Michael it's been um so
awesome chatting with you thank you so
much I've been such a big fan of yours
for years the adjustment was one of my
favorites um
but oh yeah House of Cards how could we
not save House of Cards was so great but
thank you so much and I'm so looking
forward to more special ops lioness and
everything else you have
thank you Tanya you take care nice to
see you again nice seeing you too